okay there we go oh I should wait till
30 seconds I'm waiting till 30 seconds
I'm waiting till Thursday are they
streaming
shout out okay there we go
why am I playing the king's Indian she
actually knows the stuff I think
have you been studying
no but she has like a small set of
openings that she knows
London system oh this oh no London is
the sister
ah
I'm a big lurker I know this stuff yeah
yeah I was watching the chess boxing day
already
I studied the London too some people
analyzed watching it with CP and CG
I know Laura's trying to prepared really
hard for the London system what are you
doing yeah yeah is that is that what
they call a butter scale whoa was that
real was that real she definitely did
that for the memes
oh my God
this is good content Alex thank you
thank you
wow